[Music]
we are one of the biggest loud house
fans around but we also admit that we
love Disney it's the ultimate battle of
Nickelodeon characters versus Disney
characters only this time we put them
all together
wait until you see who long aloud got
paired up with give this video a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe to our
favorite Channel now let's check out 10
the loud house kids reimagined as Disney
characters Lenny loud the 16 year old
Lenny loud wants to be a fashion
designer she definitely is the most
stylish of all of them and she really
knows how to rock those white sunglasses
we've paired her up with Cinderella
although Cinderella is 19 we see a few
similarities between the two characters
Cinderella is gentle and compassionate
she is a classic goofy princess everyone
loves on the other hand Minnie is
definitely one of the most beloved
characters in the loud house and she
cares about her siblings check out what
Lenny would look like as Cinderella
we've capped Lenny's gorgeous smile but
added Cinderella's beautiful dress Lenny
is always seen wearing her teal dress so
why not upgrade it for a gorgeous blue
gown and go to a ball just like
Cinderella Cinderella is hardworking
which isn't one of Lenny's best traits
but they both are kind-hearted
optimistic and extremely compassionate
it's you make a perfect pair the two
both have an item of clothing they're
most recognized for for Cinderella
it's her glass slipper and for Lenny
it's her white sunglasses but did you
know that the original Cinderella story
didn't feature a glass slipper we can
barely imagine Lenny without her glasses
yet alone Cinderella without her iconic
glass slipper what do you think about
this illustration make sure to let us
know in the comments just wait until you
see who Lana got paired with Lincoln
loud apart from his dad Lincoln is the
only boy in the family and he definitely
has a lot on his plate the show revolves
around him and his life with his ten
sisters who all have unique
personalities it definitely is a lot to
handle and more than often Lincoln is
the one who gets the short end of the
stick we've paired him up with Mickey
Mouse because just like winkin nikki is
the highlighted character from the
Disney family the two are always
cheerful and excited check out what
Lincoln would look like as the Mickey we
just him up and Mickey's clothes and
out of the years although you can
definitely tell this is Lincoln he
actually fits in the Mickey Mouse world
quite well did you also have very
similar personalities although we have a
feeling Nicky would spend less time
playing video games did you know that
the loud house characters started off as
rabbits that's why Lincoln has a chips
tooth and why his hair is white but did
you also know that Mickey Mouse started
off as a rabbit - we're telling you
these two are a match made in heaven and
we'd love to see this happen in real
life least allowed now this is a movie
we'd love to see in real life the four
year old Lisa loud is easily one of our
favorite loud house characters her Lisp
is too adorable and on top of that she's
incredibly smart even though she
sometimes goes just a step too far a lot
of the time Lisa works independently
from her siblings which is why we paired
her up with Moana one of the most
headstrong Disney Princesses just like
Lisa
Mariah likes to do her own thing and
doesn't really listen to anyone else
except for her heart check out with Lisa
would look like as Mona we've dressed
her in Mona's clothes and added the boat
or but last Lisa's iconic glasses and
her exasperated look her hair is also
much longer and we have to say she looks
like she's ready to kick some butt as
funny as this might look we can totally
see the Lisa Moana story happening and
we call it Moana Lisa get it did you
know that Mona's puah the pig and hey
haze the rooster were briefly based on
the movies directors
well the loud house characters were
pretty much based on Christina's life
and of all illustrations were showing
you today this one is our absolute
favorite
Lola loud Oh Lola where do we even start
with Lola loud she might just be six
years old but she clearly has a mind of
her own and it often results in plenty
of tantrums no parent ever wants to
experience but underneath her diva
attitude Lola is also headstrong and she
knows exactly what she wants
we've paired her with another
strong-willed princess and we think Lola
would be quite jealous of her lifestyle
check out what this six-year-old would
look like as a 16 year old red hair red
lips in a mermaid tail make Lola
completely unrecognizable but we all
know she loves playing dress-up and she
probably
wouldn't mind this look although we have
a feeling she's swapped the red color
for her beloved pink what do you think
good Lola pull off aerials look we'd
love to hear the listing part of your
world and we're pretty sure it would be
a hilarious moment The Little Mermaid
started off as a Disney era known as the
Disney Renaissance as it woke up many
strong-willed characters that were a lot
different from the usual Disney classics
we have a feeling the loud house and its
immediate success will definitely change
Nickelodeon's cartoon future and we
definitely want Lola loud to be part of
that cartoon world Lorie loud we also
can't forget the oldest loud sibling if
you're the youngest of the family you
know exactly what it's like to have a
sibling Mike Laurie they like to put on
boundaries and make sure their younger
siblings stay away from their room and
just like Laurie they spend more time
talking to their partner than they do to
their siblings our next Disney character
might not be the oldest in the family
but she definitely shares some of Loris
traits here's what Laurie would look
like as Nala from The Lion King it's a
perfect match isn't it knowledge would
look extremely good with blonde hair but
we also love Laurie's signature earrings
could you tell this is Laurie the two
are definitely similar in many ways Nala
is also Stern and confident and she can
definitely be fun-loving when necessary
but she's also a lion which means you
can hear her roar whenever she needs to
express herself but there's one thing
that the loud house and the Lion King
have in Commons did you know that kuba
was the first Disney character to ever
let out a fart on screen well we're
pretty sure Laurie's the first
Nickelodeon character to admit that her
top is actually her mom's old girdle
talk about gross backs new and loud
LuAnn is a comedian of the family and
it's probably best to stay out of her
way especially on days like April Fool's
but we have to admit that LuAnn would
make someone like fel a much more
hilarious character the two are complete
opposites
while bowell definitely has a sense of
humor LuAnn would take things to a new
level which is why we paired them up
together check it out LuAnn dresses
Belle we all know yellow is Luann's
signature color so she actually looks
pretty good in Belle's dress we've kept
the braces but gave her hair a Belle
makeover and made it longer and
Luminos the - we don't have a lot of
things in common although they are both
outspoken and very curious we really
want the loud house to do a Disney
character dress-up episode would you
want LuAnn to dress up as Belle or did
you have another character in mind did
you know that the original version of
Beauty and the Beast was supposed to be
much darker the original version of the
loud house didn't even feature humans we
can't imagine a rabbit making any of
Luann's puns and jokes but we can
definitely imagine the man putting on
Belle's outfit and cracking her favorite
joke
Lucy loud although she scares a lot of
people the eight-year-old Lucy loud is
one of our favorite characters she stays
true to herself her outfits and her
slightly moody personality we adore her
poems and her quirky lions even though
sometimes get scared when she appears
out of nowhere her attitude and her
personality was pair up with the one and
only mal from the popular descendants
franchise check out Lucy dress as now
she's definitely taller and even though
she can normally be seen wearing only
black and white clothing now the dark
colours was amazing on her although
we're pretty sure Lucy would ditch the
pink as fast as she could Lucy
definitely has the same mannerisms and
mal even though she's not a child of a
villain although we're pretty sure it's
one of her biggest wishes
the two are also overly sarcastic and
share many more dark traits although we
all know that Mouse evil looks are just
a facade
did you know that the actresses that
play Lucy and now have both had larger
roles before they got their roles on the
loud house indocin
Jessica's a psycho who played Lucy gave
her voice to the flame princess in
Adventure Time and dub Cameron played
both Liv and Maddie on the Liv and
Maddie show we have to say that dark
characters definitely suit them better
luna loud it's hard to decide which one
of the loud siblings is our favorite
when they all have such unique
personalities but if we had to choose
Luna would definitely be one of our top
five her rock song references are
absolutely hilarious and we adore her
hair along with her purple style another
famous Disney character known for her
long purple coat is the Evil Queen
here's what Luna would look like as the
Evil Queen we've kept her awesome hair
peeking through the crown but her purple
outfit got replaced by the Queen's
awesome coat and honestly this look
really suits her even though we feel
like Luna wouldn't be as mean-spirited
as the Evil Queen Plus this way the Evil
Queen would have a much better taste in
music did you know that the Evil Queen
was the first Disney character to ever
speak in a feature-length animated movie
we're pretty sure Luna is the first
Nickelodeon character with such awesome
sense of style and music taste the u2
would be a match made in heaven
can you imagine Luna as the Evil Queen
playing guitar yes please
Lyn loud Blinn loud is the most
competitive out of all loud siblings and
if you have a sister like her you know
what it's like every small thing turns
into a competition and she probably wins
every single time win can also be caring
although she does get slightly mean
reasonable especially when she's playing
sports we paired her up with Ursula
everyone's favorite Disney villain check
out Lynn we imagined as Ursula doesn't
she look fabulous we've kept Lynne's
hair but added Ursula is absolutely
amazing look and just like when her slow
wants to be the best we're not sure if
when is a good swimmer but since she's
good at every sport it's highly likely
the two are more alike than you think
did you know that the Little Mermaid
movie almost didn't happen because
Disney didn't like the idea at first now
imagine if Nickelodeon never got the
loud house we would never get such
awesome characters as Ursula and Lynn
and our illustration would never exist
thumbs up for competitive cartoon
characters that can make us laugh with
their weird sense of humor even though
they're sometimes completely and utterly
evil lon allowed the six-year-old lana
loud has a twin but if they weren't
together you could never tell because
the two are completely different Lana
has a much more tomboyish personality
and she loves to get her hands dirty
she's the one to call when you need to
get your toilet fixed or when the
plumbing stops working
we paired her up with the one and only
Donald Duck we've kept half of Lana's
face her red snapback and her overalls
but added the beak and the feet she
looks absolutely perfect we all know
Donald Duck is pretty funny and he
definitely doesn't take himself
seriously and Lana is exactly the same
we'd never think this combination could
work but it does Donald usually wears a
sailor shirt a cap and a red or black
bow tie but we hardly ever see him
wearing any kinds of pants
it looks like Lana's denim overalls
would definitely solve that issue we'd
love to see these Disney characters
merge with the characters from the loud
house did you know that Donald is six
years younger than Mickey Mouse it looks
like six is the number these two
characters have in common as Lana is
exactly six years old
we're pretty sure Lana would make Donald
Duck look even better if he'd finally
wear some pants and that's it for our
video for more videos like this one
check out 10 the loud house fan theories
that will blow your mind
see you next time
[Music]